splatoon the 4v4 squid ink shooter from
Nintendo is not going to feature voice
chat as apparently the developers are
concerned about hostility and negative
comments by players in an interview with
edge magazine co-director Yosuke Armano
said the decision to block online chat
was partly influenced by his own time
spent online this is coming from
personal experience when I played online
games I didn't like the negativity I got
people telling me you're crap go away so
we wanted to focus on the positive
aspects of online gaming if you're
crampin go away is the worst thing that
mr. Romano is heard on voice chat we
highly recommend he does not try any
other ftse's in splatoon you play as a
human squid known as an inkling and the
multiplayer mode pits players against
each other in squads to work together
with your team to cover the map level in
ink whoever has the most ink by the end
of the match wins currently splatoon is
set for release on when you across north
america and europe on may 29th so what
do you make of the ink shooter
abandoning voice chat do you think it's
an important feature in a team-based
tactical shooter is your crap go away
the worst you've ever had in online play
let me know in the comments and for more
stay tuned to gamespot com